während er flugzeug schlummerte hatte
eher beiläufig einen wichtigen
wendepunkt in seiner youtube karriere
erreicht hallo mein name ist luca und
ich habe bereits vor über einem jahr ein
video entdeckten namens bevor contractor
luca berühmt wurde kurzbiographie das
ist ein youtube video von dem user der
biograf und das video hat über eine
million aufrufe und ich habe auch schon
kommentiert damals mega geil gemacht
feier das video das sich damals vor
allem jahr nicht darauf reagiert habe
als ich das video gesehen habe lag
einfach daran dass ich es mir direkt
komplett angeschaut habe jetzt habe ich
das video jedoch wieder in meinen
vorschlägen irgendwie angezeigt bekommen
habt ihr in letzter zeit ja auch so
komische sachen die ich immer von
youtube vorgeschlagen werden erst dann
wollten den video vorgeschlagen die kühe
auf einem trampolin springen ja keine
ahnung was da mit youtube ratlos ist auf
jeden fall möchte ich mir das video
nochmal anschauen und da habe ich mir
gedacht bevor ich mir das jetzt alleine
noch mal anschaue schaue ich mir doch
einfach mit euch an bevor konkreter luca
berühmt wurde kam als baby nun zur ruhe
wenn er mit warmer luft aus einem föhn
an gepustet wurde als kind großer fan
der deutschen popband aller ruhe und
nuckelte sogar als zwölfjähriger noch
zum einschlafen an seinem daumen
okay das muss sie selbst nicht mal mehr
das ding ist halt dass die meisten
informationen die er hier rüber bringt
aus meinem buch stammen also dem buch
dort ich muss jetzt kurz werbevideo hier
oben ins bild schreiben weil es ja
gerade um ein buch geht das hier ist auf
jeden fall das buch was ich mit meiner
mutter beim einleben geschrieben habe
und das kannst du hier sitze ich gerade
beim scheißen auf jeden fall hat der
biograf die meisten informationen aus
meinem buch einem allerdings auch einige
sachen aus videos und was ich mal gesagt
habe und dass ich mit zwölf ja noch
genug geld habt das wusst ich selbst gar
nicht mal so als der 15-jährige luca
seine erste youtube videos
veröffentlichte war es eigentlich nicht
seine absicht mal in irgendeiner form
bekannt zu werden
das stimmt alter das weiß ich noch ich
habe angefangen und mich haben alle nur
gehälter auf youtube stimme hatte hey
leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal vier in einer zufällig
generierten welt in minecraft eure
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet gemacht mit meinem leben
also klar hätte schon gerne 1000
abonnenten gehabt aber bekannte und
familienmitglieder sollten davon
eigentlich nichts mit
stimmt ich war so brutal schüchtern
immer wenn es irgendwie bei
familienfeiern oder so darum ging hey
was hast du heute so gemacht und ich
habe halt ein video aufgenommen auf
youtube hochgeladen
das ist noch nicht die zeit wo ich mich
gezeigt habe vor der kamera das heißt
ich hab nur gespielt und man hat mich
eigentlich nicht erkennen können alle
anderen dann auf jeden fall so hey yo
ich hab im garten mitgeholfen
ich habe gekocht die auch wir haben es
gemacht gearbeitet und luca der waren
nur zocken an seinem zimmer stimmt auch
aber ich habe halt auch aufgenommen
dabei damit auch ja niemand von seiner
neuen leidenschaft erfuhr schloss er
sich nun sehr häufig in seinem zimmer
ein und wollte nicht gestört werden
sehr zur verwunderung seiner mutter die
sich große sorgen machte
mama und papa dass du verbotene dinge
kannst du mir halten europas neues
spezielles hobby verraten
das ist gerade so voll nostalgisch
entwürdigt so in das frühere luca ich
zurück katapultiert werden luca
schmerzlich in letzter zeit oft lange in
seinem kinderzimmer ein und sehen nicht
gestört werden ich bin mir sicher dass
er in der zeit keine hausaufgaben macht
denn seine noten sind deutlich
schlechter geworden oh ja das stimmt
youtube hat meinen schulabschluss
komplett in die tonne geworfen also ich
habe mein abitur gemacht ich cetera pp
und hat auch einen ganz okay im schnitt
die sache ist nur ich war die ganze zeit
ein kandidat ich weiß wenn man sich
anguckt dann denkt man es eher weniger
aber ich bin ehrlich gesagt eigentlich
wirklich nicht ganz blöd in der birne
und ich habe auch im bachelor of gemacht
neben youtube william her und da baum
mit 1 0 gegen was aber dass es darum
geht es gar nicht
es ging nur darum dass wirklich seit
youtube meinen noten kuppel den keller
gegangen sind und haben sich
selbstverständlich meine eltern auch
sorgen gemacht aber ich bin froh dass
ich damit youtuber angefangen habe und
die noten sind mir scheißegal luca macht
definitiv nichts verbotenes dass es
worauf sie hinaus möchten etwas verboten
ist das war das einzige was im kopf
seiner mutter hängen blieb auch wenn
martin kurz darauf zugegeben hatte dass
luca neuerdings videos aufnahmen
das weiß ich gar nicht ob das so stimmt
also so in etwas stimmt das schon meine
mutter hat nicht von mir direkt
mitbekommen dass sich youtube videos
mache sondern von freunden aber auch
dass martin so gesagt hat das weiß ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr sag uns doch
einfach nur mal ungefähr was sind ein
video so passiert sowas will ich auch
machen mit comtesse de channel von grund
gemeint und ein channel es so etwas wie
der sender im fernsehen ja dass mutter
verstand nur bahnhof
also zeigt dir einfach was ein vorreiter
dass es heftig gut gezeichnet dass es
heftig gut gezeigt dass seitz aus wie
ich dass die personen hier sich ein
friseur leisten kann ich weiß noch es
war so gott verdammt ähnlich meinen
eltern meinen youtube kanal zu zeigen
ich höre immer noch wenn ich mir meine
videos anschauen richtig ungern meine
stimme kennt ihr das er zeigt sie ihr
videospiele spielt sagte sein vater
später
so was guckt sich doch niemand an das
stimmt so auch nicht also stimmt schon
dass meine eltern dem ganzen sehr sehr
kritisch gegenüber eingestellt waren was
natürlich auch komplett verständlich ist
also wenn ich ein kind hätte und es wird
etwas machen was nicht auf meiner
generation ist wovon ich keine ahnung
habe dann werde ich auch eher vorsichtig
aber meine eltern haben mich wirklich
zum glück und damit auch wirklich sehr
froh darüber jetzt irgendwie dafür
fertig gemacht oder meinten halt so hey
ja okay sie meinten doch ich glaube ich
mal mehr auf die schule konzentrieren
aber wenn du das alles nebenher
hinkriegt ist alles cool habe ich dann
auch nach ein paar monaten wieder das
ist ja es stimmt da kann ich ja denn das
hat dann heiß gemacht so mit steigenden
abonnenten und steigenden einnahmen dann
auch irgendwann habe ich mir halt immer
mehr sachen gekauft um die qualität
irgendwie hoch schrauben hat sie seit
einer ganzen weile veröffentlichte luca
jetzt minecraft
mtv cribs part 5
hatte ich je sein video ein paar
sekunden später guck mal ich jetzt
kannst du noch mal das waren projekt
wird simon oh mein gott das ist ja
sechs jahre ist das her seine zuschauer
schätzten sehr dass er häufig auf ihre
wünsche eingehen und immer das machte
was ihnen gefiel eine sache konnte dabei
allerdings nicht berücksichtigen sich in
seinen videos vor laufender kamera zu
zeigen
[Musik]
das war ein riesiger schritt auch vor
allem mit meinen eltern ich weiß dass
ich dich da schon häufiger gefragt habe
aber darf ich mich auf meinem kanal
zeigen wenn du 18 bist dann kannst du
selbst über dein privatleben entscheiden
aber solange du deine videos in unserem
wlan produzierst bestimmt die regeln
also bleibt die antwort weiterhin nein
ich weiß hier auch mal das gebiet aber
wir kommen gerade wirklich die tränen er
ich kann mich eins zu eins in die
situation hineinversetzen ich habe
wirklich unfassbar lange monate lang
dafür gekämpft dass ich mich in videos
zeigen kann weil alle anderen youtuber
mit denen ich videos aufgenommen haben
die waren halt alle zwei drei jahre
älter als ich hatten schon eigene
wohnung waren dementsprechend auch schon
volljährig und konnten coole sachen
machen und auch im reallife challenges
und man konnte videos auf viel besser
gestalten wenn man so eine falsche
expression zeigen kann und so und ich
was 17 wohnt bei meinen eltern ging noch
zur schule hat noch fußball gespielt und
das war ganz schlimm auf youtube bezogen
sage ich mal die zeit für mich ich weiß
was du tun der fans ich habe wie konnte
sein vater nur so ignorant sein für den
erfolg seines youtube kanals war es
schließlich wichtig dass er sich selbst
vor der kamera zeigte
also da muss jetzt auch mein vater
wieder in schutz nehmen der war nie
ignorant habe ich dann natürlich jetzt
nicht so supported wie es beispielsweise
die eltern von dieser und lena halt lisa
und lena ins rampenlicht gestellt haben
und dann haben die irgendwie schule
abgebrochen
für youtube und so aber da bin ich auch
sehr froh darüber weil so bin ich auch
noch mal kritisch an die sache
rangegangen und jetzt im nachhinein bin
ich sehr froh dass ich mich nicht damals
schon gezeigt habe meine eltern haben
sich einfach nur sorgen gemacht
und ich glaube das ist menschlich und
ich glaube das war auch sehr sehr sehr
sehr guten kaffee diesel an
bitte name früher oder später wird das
team dachte sie sich als er stimmt da
papa halt immer noch ein bisschen mehr
abgeneigt darüber waren mama hat schon
allgemein immer die wahl die man mehr so
meine mutter ist einfach ein viel zu
lieber menschen gefunden gibt die halt
nach oder überzeugte auch papa und
letztendlich hat sie es dann erlaubt
dass das besagte video schon lange
produziert war davor die erlaubnis
erhielt verräter natürlich nicht video
wo ich mich frage schon aufgenommen
gewollt also überhaupt wurde wirkten
sehr schüchtern und dann unsicherheit
sie die fragen der zuschauer
beantworteten auch das war jetzt egal
lukas augen leuchteten vor glück ich
weiß noch dass ich mit einem kumpel von
mir mit steffen vor der kamera in berlin
bei ihm oben im zimmer weil bei mir
konnten wir das natürlich nicht drehen
weil meine eltern hätten dass er gewählt
und haben einfach so fragen von
zuschauern beantwortet und alle haben
halt nach dem video gedacht dass ich
irgendwie mit ihm zusammen sein und dass
ich schwul bin aber ich habe mich
alleine einfach vor der kamera noch
richtig unsicher gefühlt und war dann
froh dass ich einen kumpel an der seite
hat im gegensatz zu luca hatte sich
einer seiner besten freunde nach der
schulzeit eine pause gegönnt genauer
gesagt machte eine weltreise und da fand
sich jetzt für eine kurze zeit in new
york ganz uneigennützig beschloss luca
deshalb in ein paar tage gesellschaft zu
leisten ich weiß noch da war sönke in
new york und während ich in new york war
ist das clever bot video auf meinem
kanal übels viral gegangen und das war
mein durchbruch auf youtube 14 stunden
im flieger saßen seiner fans wie gewohnt
um 14 uhr ein video zu sehen bekommt
kurz nach seiner ankunft schnappen kann
sein handy und öffnete die youtube app
dort checkte er sein neues video
die website weiß alles direkt darunter
befand sich eine sehr große zahl konnte
das wirklich wahr sein
loga traute seinen augen kaum während er
flugzeug schlummerte hatte eher
beiläufig einen wichtigen wendepunkt in
seiner youtube karriere erreicht schon
wieder eine weil ich ein video von mir
selbst fehlt quasi ich weiß ganz genau
wie das war ich saß im flieger und ich
habe zu dem zeitpunkt als ich dann nach
new york geflogen bin in meiner kleinen
20 quadratmeter wohnung in köln an einer
straße vor allem saufen waren wo die
bahnen her gerauscht sind dort habe ich
gewohnt dort habe ich jeden tag videos
gemacht ich habe mich abgestufte die
sonst wasser neben meinem studium noch
für jeden tag die eh schon einen videos
machen und da noch vor zum produzieren
für new york weil ich habe seitdem ich
youtube mache keinen kater so wie jeder
andere ich mache mir kommt bekommt ein
kloster das ist so schön gemacht dieses
video ich bin das so klasse dass ich
wirklich damals schon bald sie mir das
angeschaut haben und jetzt 40 einfach
wiederholen ich weiß noch ganz genau wie
das war wir sind gelandet in new york
das erste was ich gemacht habe ist mich
mit dem handy mit dem flughafen wlan
verbunden um halt zu checken ob das
video wirklich raus gekommen ist weil
diese geplant hochladen funktion von
youtube war zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht
lange draußen und dann habe ich das halt
gesehen und dachte mir okay hat 100.000
user ist
das wäre aufgefallen sind nicht
hunderttausend fucking eine million
ich weiß nicht warum das video so krass
wie real gegangen ist war ich gesagt ein
video mit dem ich gar nicht so zufrieden
war aber es ist halt viral gegangen und
seitdem habe ich monatelang jeden monat
hunderttausende sub sorge macht
[Musik]
das war die kurzbiografie von kontraste
luca vor seien erfolgt wenn du als ich
gerade dieses bild noch mal gewartet ich
glaube dieses bild ich glaube dass sogar
das ist mein buch ja hier ist ja ich bin
eh schon immer ein mensch der bei filmen
heult und so aber jetzt bei einer
kurzbiografie die ich eh schon vor einem
jahr gesehen habe dass ich dann noch mal
drei vier mal in tränen ausbreche auch
wenn ich jetzt irgendeine seite im buch
aufmache kennt das wenn ihr euch an so
kleine sachen aus eurer kindheit
erinnert guckt man hier dabei ich bin
mit meiner schwester keine ahnung wenn
das irgendwer vielleicht irgendwie
könnte tut mir leid aber es hat ganz
ehrlich gesagt ganz gut getan zu weinen
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings ob meine lieben freunde
wenn euch das gefallen hat meine
reaktion hierauf die kurzbiografie vom
biografen anlass gerne einen daumen hoch
unter diesem video hier da ich würde
mich da sehr darüber freuen checkt auch
gern mal das video ab das habe ich euch
unten in der beschreibung verlinkt und
schreibt mir bitte mal in die kommentare
irgendwas das ist ich weiß nicht ihr
seid mir echt sehr sehr wichtig und ich
will nicht wieder in tränen ausbrechen
aber auch als ich gesehen habe wie diese
abonnentenzahlen da immer mehr gestiegen
sind das sind also ich meine wir sind
über dreieinhalb millionen
vielen dank weil ich für jeden einzelnen
weil ohne euch welche nicht ich selbst
und wahrscheinlich immer noch schüchtern
und hätte zwar ein tolles ab
wahrscheinlich hat einen master machen
und auch so habe ich noch ich wenn ich
so glücklich wie ich jetzt gerade bin
ich habe euch alle kräfte
[Musik]
das ist